[MUSIC]
Product strategy conversations
are happening without marketing executives
present.
And marketing which is really the place in
the firm where the rubber meets the road
in the sense of where
the firm meets the customer.
For marketing not to have a voice in those
conversations doesn't make any sense.
[MUSIC]
The Emerging CMO Strategic Marketing
Leadership program is a program
intended to bring marketing
back to the table.
Sure companies has CMOs, but
those CMOs don't participate
necessarily in the key strategic
decisions of the firm.
What we are looking to do with this
program is to retool emerging marketing
leaders in order to be able to serve as
that strategic marketing voice that's so
critical for the success of a firm.
>> The CEO is looking at
the CMO to provide input so
that if as the organization
begins to transform,
those inputs become relevant
because at the end of the day for
an organization to be relevant,
they have to be relevant for the customer.
>> Our programme has three
essential components.
The first component is strategic, how do
we think about the firm's strategy and
how marketing fits within it?
The second component has to do with
the customer, and here we have
an enormous depth of expertise at Stanford
on the psychology of the customer.
What is it that drives
customer experiences?
What drives customer decision making?
How do emotions fit into how customers
decide, both in B2C settings and
in B2B settings.
And the last component is leadership.
Leading is not just a matter
of having good ideas but
it's in being able to package
those ideas so people follow you.
You're experiencing this curated
content by some of the very
top faculty that the Stanford Graduate
School in Business has to offer,
really world leaders in their field.
The goal of this program is not simply
to give you tools on strategy and
understanding customers and
consumer behavior, but
also almost equally importantly to
give you the tools to then carry those
frameworks back into your company.
What we want is for our participants
to walk out of this week and say,
I got some great ideas about strategy.
The second thing is I really got
in depth understanding of
the psychology of the customer.
How is it that people out there
are thinking about their products?
How is it that they're
thinking about the market?
How are they thinking
about the competition?
How do we reach them?
Have the tools to be able to then carry
that story forward within an organization.
[MUSIC]